i remember like i don't know a year or
two ago i don't know how long ago it was
but
i read in the paper you were dating
rosaria dawson the actress and i went
holy [ __ ]
and at first i thought it was like maybe
another prank you know but what it was a
real
people were gonna believe it i didn't
like come on i finally get these
bragging rights
like good one dude she's in here
yeah i was like oh this is a this is a
stunt this woman came up to us on the
street of new orleans and
she she pointed to rosario she went
beauty and she looked at me and she went
and the beast okay i was like what the
[ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] insulting right like why
can't you be
it's so were you cracking under the
pressure no it wasn't cracking under the
pressure but there was like a couple
times where
even friends from high school like
thought i was doing a bit
i was like i'm not doing a pic i'm over
the house you're currently in a
relationship right
you're with a woman yes i met her at a
uh she's gonna be so embarrassed she's
so shy by the way she's overhearing this
or hopefully she's a i like shy
um uh i met her at a farmer's market
oh you know you're able to do that it
happens you're able to
like be at a farmers market and walk up
to someone and say hey hi
uh my name's iris it wasn't like a one
kick off i would see her there a lot and
it was like a
i would i would chat more and more often
what do you say
you walk up and go like hey i got a tv
show
no that's my opening
um no i don't know i just was trying to
be
charming and and really you know
sweet i don't i don't remember did she
know who you were
dialogue no she didn't know which is
better
yeah yeah it was better and just like
the first few dates we went on people
kept coming up like hey man can i get a
selfie and she was like what the [ __ ] is
going on why does everybody want a
selfie with this guy you had to reveal
your superpower store
that you were a famous guy who had his
own tv show in other words she had no
clue
for the first like 10 dates she would
love saying like uh
i had no idea who the [ __ ] you were and
i'm like i know right
you keep you keep bringing it up she's
like seriously like
no clue like absolutely
zero who i'm like i know babe but you
know that's starting to kind of sound
passive aggressive
the more you tell so are you in love to
the point
where we might be seeing a mrs eric
andre at some point or i mean
you want a big reveal yeah i do i want
to know where you're at with this
relationship
you know what i guarantee tonight
i will get her pregnant wow are you
trying
to you're gonna i wasn't i wasn't until
right now i'm gonna leave it
is that your next prank i'm gonna prank
myself for the next 18 years raising a
kid